dieser ort soll schutz bieten vor gewalt
und misshandlung ein flüchtlingsheim am
rande von halberstadt in sachsen-anhalt
hier werden alle untergebracht die aus
saudi arabien nach deutschland geflohen
sind es sind vor allem frauen die ein
sultan ist 29
sie erzählt den saudi arabien sei sie
misshandelt und sexuell missbraucht
worden
von ihrem 30 jahre älteren ehemann und
ihren brüdern vom saudischen staat keine
hilfe ich habe saudi arabien verlassen
damit ich in deutschland sicher leben
kann damit mein leben nicht bedroht ist
ich habe unter der ständigen bedrohung
dort sehr gelitten
doch selbst bis nach halberstadt
verfolgen sie ihre peiniger kurz nach
ihrer ankunft schreibt ihr bruder
glaubst du dass du geflüchtet bist
schützt dich ich zerstückelte dich und
hole dich zurück
dein leben ist wertlos du hündin glaub
bloß nicht dass du in sicherheit bist
das ist kaum zu fassen dass ich hier in
deutschland solche nachrichten bekomme
und mein leben bedroht wird
ich habe angst hier und befürchte das
schlimmste dass dieser ort gefährlich
für mich ist nicht nur für mich für alle
saudischen mädchen die hier sind stefan
partner hilft saudischen flüchtlingen
er erzählt sei schwer aus dem land zu
fliehen nur 139 flüchtlinge schafften es
in den vergangenen drei jahren nach
deutschland
ihre geschichten innensicht wir hören
von vielen frauen dass sie auch wenn sie
hier nach deutschland kommen weiterhin
das gefühl haben verfolgt zu werden und
sie bekommen nachrichten ihrer familien
die detailinformationen beinhalten über
ihr leben hier in deutschland
die saudische botschaft in berlin
geflüchtete frauen berichten
botschaftsmitarbeiter helfen saudischen
familien geflohener angehöriger
aufzuspüren und zur rückkehr zu zwingen
die botschaft soll angeblich sogar
spione einsätzen im flüchtlingsheim
halberstadt alles nur gerüchte
wir treffen eine asylbewerberin aus
saudi arabien die in halberstadt gewohnt
hat auch ihr mann sei gewalttätig
gewesen dürfe deshalb nicht wissen wo
sie jetzt lebt wir stellen das treffen
nach
die frau hatte die saudische botschaft
in deutschland um hilfe gebeten um ihren
mann von hier aus anzuklagen
stattdessen sollte sie spionieren ich
wurde in der botschaft in ein grün
gestrichen das büro gebracht direkt
neben dem wartezimmer dabei ein mann der
zuständig war für sein dies in
deutschland er verlangte dass sich
information and sammle über alle
saudischen asylbewerberinnen die ich
treffe ich sollte sie überreden nach
hause zurück zu gehen dann würde er mir
helfen
nach dem treffen schickt ein
botschaftsmitarbeiter namens hat keine
nachricht der chat belegt sie sollte
spionieren
der botschaftsmitarbeiter gibt
anweisungen das wichtigste wie ich es
dir schon gesagt habe überzeugt die
mädchen die du kennst zurückzukehren
dann werden alle ihre wünsche in
erfüllung gehen
und weiter wir haben diesbezüglich
befehle direkt von der führung
wir rufen die nummer an es meldet sich
am akku
er bestätigt dass er für die botschaft
arbeitet die spionage vorwürfe streitet
er ab aber die frau berichtet bei
unserem treffen am akku habe sie unter
druck gesetzt
plötzlich völlig überraschend habe er
einen rückflug für sie gebucht nach
saudi arabien
er rief mich an und befahl mir ich solle
nach berlin kommen dass ich am nächsten
tag nach wird fliegen soll
aber ich wollte das nicht ich habe mich
versteckt und nicht mehr reagiert er war
sehr sauer
wir schicken fragen an die botschaft es
kommt keine antwort
also versuchen wir es vor ort auch hier
heißt es kein kommentar bald darauf
erreicht uns dann doch noch eine antwort
aus der botschaft
zitat die anschuldigungen entbehren
jeglicher grundlage
doch es gibt weitere dubiose fälle von
einem erzählt dieser koffer er gehörte
der 21-jährigen hassa auch sie war wegen
familiärer gewalt geflohen
auch sie erhielt drohungen als sie im
heim in sachsen anhalt war aus angst
tauchte sie unter versteckte sich in
diesem zimmer bei ihrer asyl anhörung
sprach sie über ihre angst was
befürchten sie persönlich bei einer
rückkehr nach saudi arabien meine eltern
werden mich schlagen und umbringen
wir treffen eine ihrer freundinnen
rahnavard hat ein halbes jahr mit hasser
ein zimmer geteilt und ihr geholfen
die beiden waren enge vertraute doch
ihre freundin hasser ist zurück in saudi
arabien und das unter merkwürdigen
umständen eine art berichtet das wasser
einen mann kennenlernte und ihn besuchte
danach sei ihr telefon plötzlich
deaktiviert gewesen
auch ihre accounts bei instagram
snapshot und ihre e mail
uns liegt das ausreise protokoll vor
ausgestellt zwei tage nach hammers
besuch bei dem unbekannten mann
zitat am 20.8 gegen 13 uhr wurde die
saudiarabische staatsangehörige in
begleitung eines mitarbeiters der
botschaft des königreichs saudi arabien
vorstellig um alle erforderlichen
formalitäten für die ausreise in das
heimatland zu erledigen
laut dem protokoll ist es also
freiwillig zurück zu ihrer familie daran
zweifeln alle die sie kannten das
plötzliche verschwinden der
botschaftsmitarbeiter und dass die
saudische botschaft sogar ein ersatz
reisedokument besorgte mehr als
merkwürdig denn hasse hatte einen
eigenen gültigen pass nach allem was wir
wissen hilft die botschaft in familien
dabei druck auf ihre töchter oder frauen
auszuüben
ich denke dass diese taktik bewusst
gewählt ist weil diese und diese
unsicherheit die frauen haben und dieses
diese erfahrung dass die männer
letztendlich kontrolle haben das wird
ausgenutzt um hier den weiter dieses
gefühl zu vermitteln
wir fragen nach wurde hasser zur
ausreise gezwungen die botschaft hat mit
es handele sich um eine begleitete
rückführung man habe sich an recht und
gesetz gehalten und die bundesregierung
was sie über die saudischen aktivitäten
keine reaktion auf unsere fragen der
abgeordnete der linken stefan liebich
fordert von ihr schnelles handeln dass
flüchtlinge zentral untergebracht werden
halte ich für ein großes problem denn
dadurch können sie natürlich leichter
gefunden werden leichter bespitzelt
werden
und das ist auch nicht nötig man kann
die flüchtlinge dezentral überall in
deutschland unterbringen die
unterbringen unterbringung an einem ort
halte es für falsch die saudische
asylbewerberin luccin hat nach wie vor
angst dass ihre familie sie findet sie
will sich verstecken mit anderen
saudischen geflüchteten untertauchen
meine familie sucht immer noch nach mir
ich bin gewarnt worden dass jemand aus
meiner familie sogar schon in
deutschland ist der saudische start
kennt die unterkünfte in sachsen anhalt
und man wird mich dort bestimmt suchen
das flüchtlingsheim am rande von
halberstadt
unsere recherchen ergeben die behörden
mussten schon mindestens zwei saudische
frauen in sicherheit bringen vor den
nachstellungen aus saudi arabien